she roasted them I mean I just want a
fish ma'am oh no no hell you can't fish
you ain't you don't know how to fish you
don't even wear the right kind of
clothes you got damn stupid shoes on
anyway where'd you get them ugly braces
you [__]
it's like I'm like like black 20 year
olds do it she's doing it holy [__] get
your ass out of here you got license or
something I mean I just want to fish
ma'am oh no no hell you can't fish you
ain't you don't know how to fish you
don't even wear the right kind of
clothes you got damn stupid shoes on
anyway where'd you get them ugly braces
you [__]
holy [__] dude this one's great why'd
you get them ugly britches you [__]
well that's great dude what a good one